and he will be speaking about a
homological theory of functions
hello can you guys hear me
yes can you guys see me
yep yep great um
yeah so thanks for the invitation and
thanks for the very nice workshop
um today i'll talk about uh a
new a newer topic uh called homological
theory functions
and this is based on uh two papers uh
one paper by me in uh 17 and then
uh a drawing work with justin chen chris
here
uh and mongan uh all expertly people
um uh last well two years ago i guess
you know time goes fast um so
let me just jump in right away and this
is this topic is at the intersection
of uh machine learning and you know
algebraic combinatorics
so let me actually do a more like
popular science kind of intro
on this topic so uh how many of you have
heard of
alphago like who had who has not heard
of alphago raise your hand
okay good so so this is like the the
like kind of the eureka moment where
uh machine kind of unexpectedly defeated
um the world champion in go which is
like
a very very difficult problem in
artificial intelligence that was
not expected to be broken within 10
years i like probably more than that
but uh it was a very unexpected
breakthrough at the time
it's a very it's a very good um
like uh like uh the event was also very
very uh popular popularized around the
world
and uh in fact you know like there's
rumors saying that
because of this particular event china
now
like puts 100 percent of their way
behind ai and it's like now a
geopolitical situation but that's for
another topic
um okay how many have you seen uh
stuff like this where you want to like
make a website
and uh you don't know how it codes so
you just
type in some text that
that in natural language describes what
you want to make and then the machine
just puts out
spits out code for you so uh this is
done by
gpt3 so um which is like
one of the biggest language models
uh that exists right now which
essentially predicts the next word given
the previous word but you can refashion
it
in a in a way that really makes you
makes your
jaw drop in some sense that we're at
this capability
um so these these two examples are some
of the
most prominent examples of recent
advances in artificial intelligence
and it's a technology called deep
learning which is essentially
using new networks to learn certain
patterns
in nature from a large amount of data
and if you talk about uh
if you go beyond your networks and talk
about general machines
that learn from data this is called
machine learning and then
finally like a broader discipline is
artificial intelligence which is just
like use
whatever technique you can so maybe you
can do planning
and calculations other than learning
from data
to achieve some kind of intelligence so
today
i'll talk about the intersection between
machine learning
and the algebraic contours so
you know i assume most of you you know
have some basic knowledge in
combinatorics so i'm actually gonna just
delve a little bit uh into the basics of
machine learning
before i move on to connect to
algorithms
so what is machine learning so i don't
know how many you have exposure to this
but you know basic desire of a user
machine learning is that you want to
automate some tasks which has been
done by humans in a very costly way
so for example um suppose you want to
make a
hotdog detector so you use an app you
know you if you point your phone
at a whatever it tells you whether it's
a hot dog you're pointing at or it's not
a hot dog
um so for example this is like a
demonstration of what the app would look
like
um and the way you would train such a
hot dog detector
is you have data sampled so you collect
a large amount of data
and the data includes uh essentially a
bunch of pairs where each pair consists
of the input so the image of a hot dog
or not hot dog
and the human label are saying it is a
hot dog where it's not a hotdog right so
it's like a bunch of examples
um and uh
essentially we want to learn a function
uh
that that uh interpolate and extrapolate
this data but to do so we need to guess
kind of the form of the function
that would make sense so uh for example
you could guess okay
like a linear function probably would do
just fine or we can say oh maybe it's
more complicated like a neural network
uh and when you specify a form of the
function you're
specifying a function class right uh
within which you can look for the right
function
so so here's like a pictorial you know
representation of a
1d to 1d function class a bunch of sign
curves of different phases
um and you know so finally you want to
uh use some optimization technique to
find the function that
fits the data the best and can translate
to ouncing data
so maybe it's this curve um that's the
data the best
okay uh also you know if you have any
questions feel free to shout out
um all right so you can ask you know
why can't we just be lazy and put all
the functions in
this class c that i was just talking
about um
oh can we just find the optimal one
within all possible functions
and as you can imagine this is a really
giant class and
you cannot efficiently find the right
function in terms of number of examples
needed
uh or in terms of computation but
there's like but
for the topic today i'm going to focus
on efficiency in the number of
examples labels needed
um and then you can ask okay so maybe
all functions are too large but for
practically occurring c so function
class c can we find
the right interpolating function and
extrapolating function efficiently
and the answer is yes or no depending on
the class and we'll see some
examples later on and
in classical machine learning theory
uh one question one central question to
ask is for which
function class c can we find such a
function
the the fitting and extrapolating
function uh efficiently
right so in other words uh for which
function class c do we need only a few
random samples to learn the right
function
so tying back to the example of hot dog
detector earlier on
you know the data set is uh again a
bunch of pairs each pair consisting of
input image
and the label of hotdog or not and you
want to
use as little data as possible to learn
the right function because
you know if you're doing startup you
know more data means more collection
means
more more cost right and you want to
lower your cost
okay so the fewer the better and again
the question is like for which function
class c
can we uh do this in the fewest number
of samples possible
so in classical machine learning there's
an answer and i'll i'll tell you about
it
but the the topic of today is that
it turns out the answer is also that the
the the seed that have this property are
the seeds who have
simple homology and and this is kind of
a remarkable statement because
you know like classically machine
learning has never really touched
uh uh algebraic technology in really any
any way
um and here we have some kind of like
really surprising characterization
of you know efficient function classes
using uh homological techniques and
homological statements
so it's really kind of like you know
europe reached america for the first
time in some sense all right
so now let me uh now
tie back um let me describe how do we go
from
learning to topology
so again you know in machine learning
and in computer science in general we're
actually
mostly concerned uh in theoretical
communities with uh
function classes so for example in
learning theory cons
we're considering function classes from
which we want to pick the right function
that fits
and extrapolates the data in
computational complexity we consider
uh classes functions of some kind of
difficulty of computation
and the way we're going to uh use a
topological analysis or
you know a reconnaissance analysis is
we're going to associate topological
space
to the function class um
not too specific functions uh or you
know like just the input space but like
we're going to associate
the topology to the function class
itself
and we're going to analyze this
topological space using some tools like
coming to the algebra
sanity reasoner theory and cellular
resolutions um
so i won't go into a lot of detail i
don't have time to go into a lot of
detail on all of these techniques but
i i seek to give you kind of the brief
overall idea
in how do you tie these two kind of
disparate
uh fields together in the context of
learning theory
and i'll speak a little bit of a
computation complexity at the very end
but mostly i'll focus on
learning theory um
okay so now i'm gonna define
what is the topological space associated
to the class
and uh i'm gonna introduce a little bit
notation
so bracket n means the set from zero to
minus one so there are n elements
uh and then bracket into m means uh the
set of all functions
from end to end okay
so the way i'm going to define this
topological space is follows
uh if c is a class a subclass
of all the functions from n to two then
we associate the complex sc which is
separation complex
and it has vertex set given by the
product
n times two so they're two n vertices
and
you have one facet for each function uh
in the class
and the the facet has vertices given by
the graph effect
all right so so i'm i am not you know
putting a topology on the set see but
rather i'm associating it
in a kind of a dual way all right so let
me
actually delve into some examples to
flesh this out
so let's look at a very very simple
example first um
let's look at the function class from
two to two so
uh for the input space is zero one and
output is zero one
there are four such functions um
here uh each row represents a different
function and i've
i've named them the top bot identity and
negation function so you know top
essentially sends everything to one
but a sense changes everything to zero
you know identities identity negation is
obvious
okay so now uh let's look at how the
construction goes
um the vertex set is n times two
uh and we're gonna so there are four
vertices in this case because n equals
two
and we're gonna label them by the uh
yeah so we're gonna label them by these
notations which means like zero maps to
zero one that's one and so on so
okay and uh each facet
is gonna have uh the vertices given by
the graph
of the corresponding function so
for example identity is going to have
it's going to be
an edge between zero max zero and one
maps one because they describe
the identity function and so on and so
forth for the other ones
so you can notice that you know this
this forms a
diamond and it has a non-trivial
homology
uh first technology is not trivial
and okay
so let me just give you a slightly more
trivial examples to
again continue fleshing out definition
um
so you can consider instead of two to
two uh the set of functions
m two two then in general um
the complex s sub n to 2 is an
n orthoplex which in three dimensions
looks like this
and this means that it's the boundary of
the convex hall
of the coordinate vectors plus and minus
coordinate vectors in rn
right okay so homologically this is a
sphere
and the n minus one degree homogen is
equal to z
um but for more general and non-trivial
c like strict subclasses of the full
cost of functions
uh s sub c is a subcomplex of an
orthoplex
which is uh obtained by picking a subset
of the facets
and looking at the sub subcomplex
generated
by the subset
okay so this is the final example just
to look at something
more non-trivial not just like the order
flex uh with the non-trivial homology
so so here let's look at f2 linear
functionals
so here the input space are the
non-zero column vectors in f2 squared
so there are three of those and the
function class
is the set of linear functionals which
you can think of as row vectors
in the dual space of ft squared
and this table shows you the graph
of these functions so in each row we
have a different function
like the left column is are the names of
the function which are represented by
row vectors
right and the the these entries
uh signify the values of the function
taking on different inputs where each
each column corresponds to different
input right so for example the zero zero
function since
zero the zero one function you know
sends zero one to one because the inner
product of those two things
is one okay so
um we're gonna look at the the complex
associated to
the space of functions and um
you so it looks like this so again it's
a subcomplex
of the uh three to two uh complex which
is the orthoplex in three dimensions so
uh that's why this kind of looks like
you know this
looks like a subcomplex of the autoplex
given by the
subsample of the facets
and each facet is a triangle where for
example the one zero facets
has the vertex zero one to zero one one
two one and
one zero to one because those are the
values of the function
um and if you you can like visualize
this
better by using an animation uh
and so in short it looks like this
complex looks like
the uh choosing every other facet in the
orthoplex in three dimensions okay so
here the uh the homology is you know not
just a sphere right
it's uh you can you can see that the
homology is a
z3 z to the third power in
the first degree and nothing else
all right so hopefully that gave you
some idea
of what the complex looks like and how
it's defined
let me pause here for any questions
all right sounds good so
um now i'm gonna actually tie back uh
and talk about the connection between
homology and learning
so the statement i want to eventually
make informal is the following
so the amount of data needed to learn an
unknown function
in a class c is controlled by the
homology of c
so by hama gc i mean like the homology
of the
complex associated you see
um and a little
going a level deeper i want to say that
the amount of data
is controlled by the highest dimension
of any hole in c so in other words like
you know like uh kind of something like
the highest non-managing degree of the
homology in c
but this is actually not quite right uh
so let me
just define uh one more thing the length
of uh of a subset in the sentence
complex before i finally
come back and give you the false
statement but um
so the length of a subset of vertices
inside of the material complex
is essentially the set of faces that are
destroying from the subset
but whose union with the subset lie in
the complex so this this is kind of
mouthful and maybe takes a second to
digest
so let me give you an example so in the
complex
uh i just uh described uh in
in two dimensions um we can look at
the link of the vertex 0 to 0.
and so essentially we're going to look
at the cone
which is the the subset of the complex
given by the kong with the vertex
at zero to zero which is you know
essentially adding
in these two vertices along with the
connecting edges
and the the link is just the base of
this cone
so this these two points okay and
more generally you know you can look at
a link of any subset not just a
singleton
and the the intuition is that you're
going to look at
kind of a cone generated from the subset
and then you look at the base of that
subset
uh the base of that coin
okay so um
the the more precise statement is that
the amount of needed the amount of data
needed to learn
a function in class c is controlled by
the highest dimension
of any hole in c or any of these links
and uh the reason we
look at links uh instead of just the
homology of the
compact itself is that um
you can kind of add triviality
uh to a function class by saying like
all functions map to zero to zero and
that would change the
homology of the the parent complex
associated with the class
by essentially adding a vertex which is
the cone vertex over everything else
which trivializes homology but if you
look at all of the links you can
remove the tree of triviality and this
definition
makes a lot more sense so
we define this as the homological
dimension of c
um offset by one uh and formally is
given
as as follows so the homological
dimension of a function class c
uh dim hc is defined as the max
uh over i where the if homologic
homology
is not zero for some link
in the complex plus one
okay so so so far i'm just defining
uh the complex and the homological
dimension and
uh shortly i'm going to tie it back to
any of you but any questions so far
so hopefully this should be all quite
natural too
like there are quite natural definitions
oh so there's a question in the chat
euron asks given your relating class of
functions to homology does it make sense
to
speak of the homotope type of the class
of functions
uh yeah it definitely makes sense uh but
i haven't calculated it i am not sure uh
my intuition is probably pretty hard to
calculate especially these
um these complexes are like really high
dimensional
um and so like a lot of the
classical techniques might fail in
the setting uh and and the way you know
uh i've been able to kind of like
handle the homologies through like any
reason or theory and like kind of look
at the
cellular resolution of the uh the sandy
reasoner
ideal um but um
yeah it's a good question i just i don't
really uh know
a good answer to uh to the
homotopic type of the complexes okay
thank you
[Music]
okay so now i'm gonna come back to
the other side the learning theory part
and
um i'm gonna define this thing called
the vc dimension which is
a classical notion in learning theory
and it relates back to the
number of samples needed so the vc
dimension of a class
c which is subset of
n to two is defined as the max
of a max carnality of a subset u
of the input space n such that the
restriction of c to u
is equal to the entire class of
functions on u
so you do too um
so this is again you know kind of like a
very condensed uh definition
uh it might take you a little bit to
grock it
um but essentially we're saying you know
like what's the
what's the subset uh on which c
essentially
describes all of all the possible uh
ways to uh to
to yeah all the possible functions on
that subset
and we say c shatters you if the
condition above
is satisfied uh so
i'll come back to this a bit later and
it's a classical theorem
in learning theory that the number of
samples needed to learn the correct
function
in c is the most constant multiple of
the
vc dimension of c
okay so so this is just one slide on
some
basic background in the classical
learning theory
um so now let's put it all together so
why would homology matter
in learning theory and the key theorem
is that the vc dimension is bounded
above by the homological dimension of c
um for all uh yeah for all possible
function class c
and probably i think that itself is kind
of remarkable but
the more surprising thing to me is that
for
a lot of different classes uh of
functions you actually achieve
equality so these so these are some
examples
where um they occur uh very commonly in
classical learning theory
so polynomial thresholds or monotone
conjunctions uh so on so forth
you can look at these um and
uh you have equality of those uh two
quantities
in uh all these cases which is just that
there's like some something fundamental
uh going on but in general uh they're
not
actually equal so we cannot hope for you
know a tight
uh coupling between those two things but
the fact that they're
uh equal for a lot of things a lot of
classes of interest in learning through
is very very interesting
okay um okay so now
this is uh the la the last slide on
the learning direct part uh but i'm
which i'm just going to talk about
um uh like what what kind of
what kind of math goes behind goes on
behind the scenes so
how do we prove the inequality uh
i discussed earlier and in general how
do you go about analyzing the situation
so um like i said you know see
uh the vc dimension
is defined as the largest the size of
the largest set u
that is shattered by c which means that
if you restrict the function class c
to the subset u then you're going to get
back all the functions
on you okay so
so the first step of the argument
is that c shatters you
if and only if the complex
restricted to u times 2
is isomorphic to a sphere of dimension u
minus 1.
so this is fairly straightforward
so for example um in uh
yeah in in this example um we can say we
can look at
um like the zero one
two zero and one zero to one and uh
yeah the there's oh sorry uh we can look
at um
yeah we can look at the the middle uh
rectangle uh square
in the middle and uh yeah
you can see that like because this uh
the this function class shatters the
the 1 0 1 0 1 1 subset
of the sub complex here
in the middle is you know a diamond
which is homologically a sphere
um so so this is a equivalent so c
shatters you even only if
the restriction of the complex to u
times two
is isomorphic to a sphere of the right
sides
um and then the second step
uh is now we introduce homology so it
turns out that you know uh
this is true if you make the statement
that
um uh s of c restricted u times two is
homologically sphere
if and only if it's a homeowner vector
sphere
and then finally you you want to say
that the subset u
so so again u is any subset that c
shatters
and you want to say that this set has
cardinality at most
the homological dimension c uh via
machinery insanity regional theory which
i don't have time
to go through in detail but essentially
what you what you do
is you look at the um the face ideal
of the complex which are
essentially encoded by monomials which
correspond to
non-faces in the uh in the complex
and then you look at the the dual ideal
of this guy and then
you want to essentially look at the uh
you can you want to resolve this idea
and look at homologies
and this homology relates back to the
homology
of the original complex so
uh yeah unfortunately i don't have you
know enough time to go into this in
detail
so so that's all i'm going to
talk about about the intersection of
learning theory and algebraic
topology or algebraic karma torques
any questions here
okay so um the last couple slides i'm
just gonna briefly go through
uh some other kinds of results in uh
in this intersection of algebraic common
torques
and theoretical computer science
so one application is in complexity
theory so
in complexity theory you study
complexity classes which are function
classes
defined by difficulty of computation so
for example p
is a is a very famous class of functions
which is just saying which is defined by
saying that the
the function in the class uh have
polynomial runtime
in the size of the input and np
is means the set of functions for which
the
answer can be verified in polynomial
time in the size of the input
and commutation complexity studies the
relationship between these different
company classes
and the most famous problem within which
uh is
the p equals mp problem and
our work you know provides a homological
invariance for complicity classes
so you know like if you want to show p
is not equal to mp you might be able to
show that they have different homologies
of course it's still very hard to show
but just just as an example
uh this is kind of the strategy and
in our work we demonstrate this
homological technique by separating
classes
of the class of polynomial threshold
functions from the class of parity
functions
and essentially the idea here is that if
you add the parity function to the
polynomial threshold function you can
show that like there's a homology that
is killed
by uh by this action and as such like
the
the the function classes are different
um and some other results are as follows
so
a function f is a polynomial threshold
if and only if
f kills the homology of the class of
polynomial thresholds
when you add the function to the class
um
another one is that fitting a polynomial
threshold function has no superior
local minimum and uh finally i think
something super interesting is that this
homological theory functions
is a homologous theory of specific kinds
of cauchys
which are inspired due to the chromology
and this has relation to um
like probably probabilistic random
function
classes so some
some of the open questions here
are as follows so can we exactly
characterize
when homological dimension equals vc
dimension
uh i think this is a really really
beautiful question
uh but i yeah you might be
out of reach at the moment um
another question is how what data does
the euler polynomial or the however
function of the complex
tell us about the function class um
and what other complex separations can
we prove using these homological
invariants
and finally can we use the koshi
perspective to send our results to
randomized competency classes great
and that's it uh thank you these are the
two papers
involved in this talk feel free to look
them up
and i welcome any questions
okay so let us thank the speaker for a
great talk
and feel free to unmute yourself and ask
questions or type them in the chat and i
can read them out